MY COLLEAGUE BRET BAIER TALKED
WITH CONGRESSMAN MOEN EARLIER
TODAY.
BACK FROM THE REGION WHICH HE
SAID HE PAID FOR HIMSELF AND
WITH THE HELP OF PRIVATE
CONTRIBUTIONS.
>> Bret: MIKE, THANK YOU.
JOINING US NOW REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSMAN MARK WANE MULLEN
FROM OKLAHOMA.
JUST HAD AN INTERESTING TRIP
OVERSEAS.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
>> Bret: START AT THE BEGINNING.
HOW DOES THIS START?
>> WELL, I WANT TO MAKE IT VERY
CLEAR.
I WASN'T LOOKING TO TRY TO GET
IN AFGHANISTAN.
THAT WASN'T WHAT WAS THIS THING
STARTED OUT TO BE.
WHAT STARTED WAS PEOPLE STARTED
CALLING ME WANTING HELP.
AND WE HAD BEEN GETTING FRIENDS
OF MINE THAT WAS IN THE SERVICE
THAT SAID CAN YOU HELP OUR
INTERPRETER GET OUT?
WHICH WE HAD A LOT OF
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THAT.
THEN WE STARTED GETTING PHONE
CALLS FROM PEOPLE THAT HAD
FAMILY MEMBERS OR FRIENDS THAT
WERE AMVETS OR AMERICAN CITIZENS
AM SETS FOR SHORT.
LET ME MAKE A PHONE CALL IT CAME
OUT THEY NEEDED A STATE
DEPARTMENT OR A GOVERNMENT
ENTITY TO SPONSOR THEIR FLIGHT
GOING.
IN THAT'S THE ONLY WAY THEY
COULD GET IN.
AND NO ONE WOULD SPONSOR THEIR
FLIGHT.
EVEN THOUGH IT WAS -- DESIGNATED
TO GET THESE 20 AMERICANS OUT.
AND SO THEY CALLED ME BACK AND
SAID WOULD YOU BE INTERESTED IN
SPAWRNG THE FLIGHT?
AND I SAID I MEAN, WHAT DO YOU
MEAN FINANCIALLY?
AND THEY SAID NO,
CONGRESSIONAL -- A CONGRESSMAN
CAN SPONSOR A FLIGHT GOING IN
AND IT GIVES ONE OF THESE OTHER
DEPARTMENTS COVER BECAUSE IT'S
KIND OF NO ONE WANTS TO TOUCH IT
BECAUSE I PERSONALLY BELIEVE,
BRET, IT WAS BECAUSE THEY KNEW
THIS WAS A HOT NEST.
THAT'S HOW THIS THING HOLE THING
STARTED.
>> Bret: SO YOU DON'T ACTUALLY
GET INTO AFGHANISTAN TO GET
PEOPLE OUT?
>> AS THIS THING MOVED FORWARD
IS THEY WANTED -- EVERYBODY KEPT
DENYING THEM AND THEN THEY ASKED
WOULD YOU GO WITH US?
AND THESE ARE TIER 1 OPERATORS.
THESE ARE DELTA GUYS, SPECIAL
FORCES.
THESE GUYS ARE LEGIT.
I'M NOBODY.
I'M JUST A CONGRESSMAN.
>> Bret: YOU ARE A CONGRESSMAN
FROM OKLAHOMA.
YOU ARE A BUSINESSMAN.
>> SURE.
>> Bret: MIXED MARTIAL ARTS BACK
GROUND BUT NO MILITARY, RIGHT?
>> THAT DOESN'T PLAY WELL IN
THIS.
I WASN'T TRYING TO GO OVER THERE
AND BE A COWBOY OR ANYTHING LIKE
THIS.
WHAT ELSE DO YOU DO?
WHEN YOU SEE A PROBLEM, HOW DO
YOU SAY NO IF YOU CAN BE AN
ASSET THEY BELIEVED THINK COULD
BE AN ASSET.
WE GOT A HUMANITARIAN FLIGHT
PLAN FROM FAA.
AND EVERYTHING WAS GOOD TO GO.
WE LEFT.
WE HAD LEFT THE UNITED STATES.
WE HAD A TIME OF ARRIVAL IN THE
KABUL WITH HIGH KIA THE AIRPORT
THERE IN KABUL.
WE GOT THERE AND ON APPROACH AND
THEY CANCELED OUR PPR.
SO WE CIRCLED THE AIRPORT
PROBABLY FOR AN HOUR.
AND WE HAD FIVE PPRs CANCELED.
EVERY TIME THEY CANCELED THE
AGENCY THAT WAS TRYING TO GET US
IN, WOULD GIVE US A NEW ONE.
THEY ACTUALLY WENT INTO THE
TOWER TO SAY LET THEM LAND.
WE WERE ON THE PHONE WITH THEM
TEXTING.
WE COULDN'T TALK.
WE WERE TEXTING BACK AND FORTH
AND THEY KEPT ISSUING US A NEW
ONE.
AND THEY WOULD NEVER LET US IN
AFGHANISTAN.
I WILL TELL YOU THIS, TOO.
UNFORTUNATELY, ONE OF OUR
AMERICAN CITIZENS HER 2-YEAR-OLD
SON AND I BELIEVE IT WAS HER
FATHER TO WHICH I HAD PASSPORTS
ON WE LOST CONTACT ON BECAUSE
THEY WERE AT THE ABBEY GATE AND
A FEW HOURS LATER THE ABBEY GATE
BLEW UP.
WE HAVEN'T HAD ANY CONTACT WITH
THEM SINCE.
I BELIEVE IT'S BECAUSE THEY WERE
CAUGHT UP IN THAT.
SO WHAT THEY DID BY PLAYING
POLITICS ON THAT, FOR WHATEVER
REASON.
>> Bret: SO YOU DON'T KNOW WHO
SHUT YOU DOWN FROM LANDING?
>> I DON'T KNOW WHO SHUT US
DOWN.
BUT I THINK IT WAS 100 PERCENT
DIRECTED FROM THE STATE
DEPARTMENT.
>> Bret: AT SOME POINT YOU GO ON
TO TAJIKISTAN.
>> NO.
I NEVER WENT TO TAJIKISTAN.
>> Bret: DIDN'T GO IN?
>> THAT IS ABSOLUTELY FALSE.
WE DID WORK AROUND THE REGION.
BUT TAJIKISTAN WAS UNFORTUNATELY
THE AMBASSADOR WAS NOT HELPFUL
AT ALL.
AND A LOT OF MISINFORMATION WAS
GOING OUT ABOUT THAT.
>> Bret: AND FOR THE STORY LINE
THAT SAID THAT YOU POSSIBLY
INTERRUPTED SOME COVERT THING
THAT WAS GOING ON OR SOME
SEPARATION TAJIKISTAN?
>> NO.
I DON'T -- I DIDN'T HAVE A CLUE
WHAT THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT.
THIS IS WHAT THE AMBASSADOR TOLD
ME.
HE SAID IT'S VERY SENSITIVE
RIGHT NOW MARK WAYNE.
IT'S PUTIN AND THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT IS GOING TO BE HERE
SEPTEMBER 5TH.
IT'S VERY SENSITIVE.
I SAID I GET IT'S VERY
SENSITIVE.
I DON'T NEED YOUR ASSETS.
I FIRST OF ALL WAS MAKING YOU
AWAY THAT WE'RE COME IN.
I ALSO AND I ALSO MADE THE POINT
I SAID BUT WE ARE COMING IN WITH
A LARGE SUM OF CASH.
WHY ARE YOU COMING WITH A LARGE
SUM OF CASH?
SIR, DO YOU KNOW THAT WE GOT TO
GO THROUGH 16 CHECKPOINTS JUST
TO GET FROM KABUL TO -- EACH ONE
OF THOSE CHARGE SOMEONE TO COME
THROUGH.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
REQUIREMENTS ARE.
WHAT ARE THE REQUIREMENTS OF
BRINGING THIS CASH?
AND HE SAYS I CAN'T ASSIST YOU.
I CAN'T HELP YOU.
WHY?
I WAS TOLD NOT TO.
YOU WERE TOLD NOT TO HELP AN
AMERICAN CITIZEN?
YOU WERE TOLD BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IN WASHINGTON, D.C.
NOT TO HELP WHEN WE'RE NOT
TRYING TO SMUGGLE ANYBODY OVER.
WE'RE TRYING TO DO A JOB THAT
PRESIDENT BIDEN WOULDN'T DO.
>> Bret: YOU KNOW, A LOT OF
PEOPLE LOOK AT WHAT YOU WERE
TRYING TO DO AS ADMIRABLE.
YOU HAD HOUSE MINORITY LEADER
KEVIN McCARTHY SAYING HE
REALLY DIDN'T WANT MEMBERS DOING
THIS ON THEIR OWN BECAUSE ONE,
THEY COULD PROXIMATE CAUSE
HOSTAGES.
TWO, THEY COULD BECOME PROBLEMS
THAT THE MILITARY WOULD HAVE TO
DEAL WITH.
>> SURE.
>> Bret: DO YOU THINK ABOUT THAT
WHETHER THAT WAS WORTH IT.
>> I DID.
BUT, HOW DO YOU SAY NO?
I MEAN, HOW DO YOU SAY NO WHEN
YOU HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO
SOMETHING.
BELIEVE ME MY HAPPY WASN'T HAPPY
ABOUT ME GOING.
>> Bret: I'M SURE.
>> MY KID WASN'T HAPPY WITH ME
ABOUT GOING.
QUITE FRANKLY WITH ALL OF YOU
ALL OF US ON THAT PLANE WE FELT
LIKE WE PROBABLY HAD A 50/50
CHANCE OF COMING BACK.
>> Bret: I ACTUALLY THINK THIS
WAS BRAVADO TESTOSTERONE OR
EFFORT TO GET THE SPOTLIGHT.
>> I UNDERSTAND THAT.
>> Bret: HOW DO YOU RESPOND TO
THAT.
>> I NEVER PRETENDED TO BE
RAMBEAU.
WE WERE SURROUNDED BY GREAT
PEOPLE.
OF ALL THE GUYS I'M WORKING WITH
I'M THE LOW MAN ON THE TOTEM
POLE.
THEY FELT I COULD BE OF
ASSISTANCE TO THEM.
HOW?
LOGISTICALLY MAYBE MAKE PHONE
CALLS AND BEING ABLE TO TAKE IN
THE SIVs OR THE AMSITS AS THEY
CAME ON THE PLANE.
THAT WAS THE PLAN.
THAT PLAN CHANGED AND IT CHANGED
WHEN WE WASN'T ALLOWED TO GET
INTO AFGHANISTAN.
WE QUICKLY REALIZED THAT THE
PRESIDENT AND THE STATE
DEPARTMENT GENERAL MILLE,
GENERAL MCKENZIE WILL LYING TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE BY SAYING
EVERYBODY WHO WANTED OUT COULD
GET OUT THAT IS A LIE.
THAT A BOLDFACED 100 PERCENT LIE
BECAUSE WE WERE WORKING WITH
THESE INDIVIDUALS.
>> Bret: YOU KNOW TODAY THAT
THERE ARE JUST A BUNCH OF THEM
STILL STUCK THERE?
>> RIGHT NOW AS WE SPEAK, RIGHT
BEFORE WE STARTED TALKING, I
CALLED THE GUYS THAT ARE STILL
OVER THERE AND THEY SAID THERE
WAS FIVE PLANES SETTING AT MEZ
WITH ANSITS, SIVS.
>> Bret: AMERICAN CITIZENS.
SPECIAL VISAS.
>> REFUGEES WE CAN GET OUT.
THEY CAN'T GET CLEARANCE TO GET
OUT BECAUSE NO COUNTRY IS WILL
TO HELP THEM.
WE CALLED THE STATE DEPARTMENT
ABOUT THIS.
THE STATE DEPARTMENT SAID WE ARE
NOT IN CONTROL OF THE AIRSPACE.
WE'RE NOT HANDLING ANY OF THAT
WELL IT'S OUR MESS.
I DON'T CARE WHICH WAY YOU THINK
ABOUT IT.
IT'S OUR MESS.
THE UNITED STATES CREATED THIS
VACUUM TO ALLOW THE TALIBAN TO
COME IN.
THE PRESIDENT PRESIDENT BIDEN
AND HIS HORRIFIC WITHDRAWAL HAS
CAUSED THIS TO HAPPEN.
>> Bret: DO YOU HAVE ANY REGRET
ABOUT WHAT DID YOU?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
I WOULD DO IT AGAIN TOMORROW.
WE WERE SAVING PEOPLE'S LIVES.
>> Bret: WHAT IF 535 MEMBERS
DECIDE TO GET ON A PLANE.
>> EVERYBODY IS HELPING RIGHT
NOW.
I DON'T CARE IF THEY ARE
REPUBLICAN OR DEMOCRAT.
EVERYBODY IS HELPING.
I HAVE HEARD FROM A LOT OF
DIFFERENT MEMBERS THAT ARE
TRYING TO DO THEIR THING.
EVERYBODY HAS A DIFFERENT WAY OF
HELPING.
DO YOU KNOW WHY THOSE ALL THOSE
OTHER GOVERNMENTS ARE PICKING UP
THEIR INDIVIDUALS AND BRINGING
THEM BACK IN?
THERE WAS THREE TALIBAN
CHECKPOINTS BEFORE YOU COULD GET
TO HIGH KIA, ALL THREE OF THEM
WOULD CHARGE YOU A TAX.
AND A TAX WAS ANYWHERE BETWEEN
500 TO $4,000.
THIS ONE YOUNG LADY AND HER FOUR
KIDS TO WHICH I HAVE RECORDINGS
OF, WE WERE RECORDING AS WE WERE
WALKING THROUGH BECAUSE I WAS ON
THE PHONE WITH THE STATE
DEPARTMENT FOR 12 HOURS TRYING
TO GET SOMEONE FROM THE STATE
DEPARTMENT TO COME OUT OF THE
GATE TO GET HER FOR 12 HOURS.
12 HOURS.
I HAVE IT RECORDED.
COULDN'T GET ANYBODY TO COME
OUT.
SHE HAD TO COME THROUGH THERE.
IT COST HER $2,000.
OF THEY -- THE STATE DEPARTMENT
KEPT SAYING HEY, GO UP AND TALK
TO THEM.
TELL THEM THEY'RE WAITING ON US.
GIVE THEM YOUR NAME.
THEY KNOW YOU ARE COMING.
FIVE TIMES SHE APPROACHED THIS
GUARD WITH THE TALIBAN, THE LAST
TIME THEY STUCK A PISTOL TO HER
HEAD WITH HER KIDS THERE.
I HAVE IT RECORDED WITH HER KIDS
SCREAMING AND CRYING.
SHE GOES BACK AND SHE -- SHE IS
CRYING SO HARD THAT SHE BEGINS
TO PUKE.
THE MOTHER DID.
AND THE STATE DEPARTMENT SENT
HER UP THERE FIVE TIMES SAYING
WE HAVE CLEARANCE FOR HER.
HERE WE ARE THE UNITED STATES
GOVERNMENT AND WE ARE
NEGOTIATING WITH THE TALIBAN TO
GET AMERICAN CITIZENS OUT AND
THEN THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES IS GOING TO GO TO THE MIC
AND SAY THAT EVERY AMERICAN THAT
WANTED OUT GOT OUT?
I HAVE A LIST OF 50 THAT WANT
OUT THAT THEY HAVEN'T GOT OUT.
I HAVE A LIST OF 50 THAT WE HAVE
RAN OUT OF KABUL AND PUT IN SAFE
HOUSES AROUND AFGHANISTAN THAT I
PROMISE YOU THEY WANTED OUT.
>> Bret: DO YOU THINK WE ARE
GOING TO GET THESE PEOPLE OUT?
>> WE'RE GOING TO GET SOME BUT
THERE IS GOING TO BE SOME THAT'S
GOING TO DIE BECAUSE OF THE
FAILURE FROM PRESIDENT BIDEN.
I PROMISE YOU THAT.
AT SOME POINT THEY ARE GOING TO
LOSE PATIENCE AND AREN'T GOING
TO LET KEEP US DRIVING PAST
CHECKPOINTS AND PAYING THEM OFF.
SORRY, TAXES.
THAT'S WHAT THEY CALL IT, TAX.
AND WHEN I SAY THAT BLOOD IS ON
HIS HANDS, THAT MEANS PRESIDENT
BIDEN'S HANDS?
I MEAN THAT WITH EVERYTHING IN
MY HEART.
IT'S HIS FAULT.
I WOULDN'T HAVE BEEN OVER THERE
I WOULDN'T HAVE EVEN THOUGHT
ABOUT GOING IF IT WASN'T FOR HIS
FAILURE.
I WOULDN'T HAVE PUT MY LIFE IN
DANGER.
I WOULDN'T HAVE PUT MY KIDS AND
MY WIFE THROUGH THAT I WOULDN'T
HAVE PUT ANYBODY THROUGH IT.
>> Bret: AND YOU WOULD DO IT
AGAIN.
>> WITHOUT EVEN HESITATION.
>> Bret: TEXT MESSAGE
CONGRESSMAN.
WE APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
I KNOW YOU JUS